the shifting epidemic has a new center
bolton now has the highest rate in the
country with 120
coveted cases for every 100 000 people
a sudden sharp rise that has brought
swift action from the government
cafes restaurants and pubs will be only
allowed to sell
takeaway food and drink they'll have to
close at 10 pm
and it'll be illegal for people to mix
with other households
this restaurant owner says the area's
entire hospitality industry
is paying for poor social distancing in
just a handful of businesses
how do you then monitor all these
businesses
the answer is you can't so they have to
have
a brush right across the board i'm sorry
but
there's going to be a lockdown i
understand that but it is unfair
further government action is also
expected nationally
with a reduction in the number of people
legally allowed to meet socially being
reduced from
30 to six across the country cases are
beginning to climb
though in most areas they are still at a
low level
speaking in the house of commons the
health secretary warned against
complacency
this must be a moment of clarity for us
all
this is not over just because we've come
through one peak
it doesn't mean we can't see another one
coming towards our shores
but together we can tackle it so long as
we remember that in a pandemic
our actions today have consequences
tomorrow
each and every citizen has a
responsibility to follow social
distancing and help stop a second speed
peak so is this the beginning of a
second wave
at the start of july the virus had been
largely confined to a small number of
local flare-ups
but this was the national picture by the
end of august over the summer the virus
has started to spread much more widely
again
there have been similar rises in other
european countries
in france which eased lockdown seven
weeks earlier than the uk
the number of cases has increased
sharply and has also been
a small but steady increase in deaths
and in spain
where cases have risen even more rapidly
the number of deaths is up 15 times
since july
as the young infect the old that's the
worry
the uk might just be a few weeks behind
on the curve
i hope we can modify our behavior now
coming in you know the next few weeks
and
and and months and uh
and so we don't see an increase we we
can
hold it in some way at where we are at
the moment i
i'm not confident that we can do that
right now it doesn't look
like that and so i i think um
i think if cases go up i think it is
very likely that deaths will go up
eventually
in wales too there is a rise in cases
with kefilli now in lockdown
no one is allowed in or out without good
reason
it's a warning to us all stick to social
distancing
or face the consequences thomas more sky
news